ليله بدايه دعينا نشير الى هذا الخبر
العاجل الان الذي جاء على من طرف الجيش
الاسرائيلي واعلن رسميا عن اصابه 35
عسكريا اسرائيليا في معارك قطاع غزه في
الساعات ال4 الماضيه اذا العدد هو
35 جنديا وبذلك يرتفع عدد الجنود والضباط
الذين اصيبوا بحسب الاعلان الرسمي الاس من
جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الى 2600 وجنديان وعدد الجنود منذ
بدايه المعركه البريه الى
1152 جنديا فيما وصل عدد القتلى في صفوف
الجيش الاسرائيلي بين جندي وضابط الى
527 ونشير ايضا الى ان عدد الجنود الذين
اصيبوا بجروح خطيره جراء المعارك البريه
يبلغ
396 جنديا اذا اخر الاحصائيات من جانب
الجيش الاسرائيلي تتحدث عن اصابه 35 جنديا
اسرائيليا في معارك قطاع غزه في الساعات
ال 24 الماضيه وهذا ليلى بخلاف ما كان
اعلن عنه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي عن
انخفاض مستوى العمليات العسكريه على الاقل
في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه ذلك ان
ايضا الضابط والجندي الذين قتلا في معارك
الساعات الاخيره قتلا في شمال قطاع غزه
وليس في وسطها وجنوبها وهذا يعني بان
العمليات العسكريه مستمره ومتواصله على
اكثر من محور وفي اكثر من مكان حتى في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه ونحن نرى فعلا
ان القصف المدفعي والغارات الجويه ما زالت
مستمره وان كانت بوتيره مختلفه عن الايام
الاولى للعمليه البريه والاسابيع الماضيه
لكن هنالك قصف مدفعي يطال بعض الاحياء في
جباليا وكذلك في المناطق الشماليه
والشرقيه والجنوبيه لمدينه غزه هنالك من
يلوم حقيقه ليلى الجيش الاسرائيلي على
قرار سحب الفرقه 36 من داخل قطاع غزه على
اعتبار ان حركه حماس عادت لتملا هذا
الفراغ وهم يلومون الجيش الاسرائيلي ومن
اتخذ هذا القرار ويقولون بان ذلك يشكل
خطرا وقد يؤدي الى ضحايا بشريه في صفوف
الاسرائيليين استمعنا الى ما قاله في هذا
السياق وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ايتمار بنفير وعدد اخر من الوزراء الذين
ابدوا معارضتهم الشديده لسحب القوات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه من داخل قطاع غزه
وقالوا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم ينجز بعد
المهمه و